i've come to london zoo to meet hannah
to tell her to stop monkeying around
when it comes to her diet
hannah has worked here as zookeeper and
animal nutritionist for the past four
years
my job here is mostly to look after the
um the primates so all the monkeys and
the apes good morning
yes
each day hannah prepares peanuts and
meal worms for the squirrel monkeys
the chimps get fresh papaya
the mama sets banana
and bobby the silverback griller enjoys
a sumptuous spread of seeds fennel and
curly kale
like most of her charges hannah doesn't
eat meat but she's not looking after
herself half as well as the monkeys and
it's beginning to show
i've recently um got a gluten and dairy
intolerance so every day at work i
basically have the same thing it's
either gluten-free pasta with pesto or a
baked potato
pasta and baked potatoes every day
hannah's clearly not getting enough
variety in her restricted diet
and i think her main problem is lack of
protein
hannah good morning how are you i'm very
well thank you it's like a blown-up
version of anti-roll thompson
the diet is crucial yes absolutely
vegetable intake vitamin c you know
protein yeah and that balance is the
most important part yeah absolutely when
was the last time you sat down to a
really good piece of meat
uh
a good good three three and a half years
ago any reason
i think having started at the zoo you
kind of start to get a different outlook
on on the on how animals are treated the
sort of meat that you eat
i've always been i was always careful
about what meat i ate before so you
would eat meat if it was you know yeah
probably uh red organic absolutely
bobby the silverback griller is a great
example of what a healthy balanced diet
can do for you
bobby
there we go somebody's he's having this
fruit tea now
fruit tea i'm surprised he's not my el
grey
it's lunch time for bobby and the other
animals so hannah and i are off to make
it
right this is our cutting-up room this
is like a prep room for a restaurant
you've got the frizzy lettuce cabbage
cardamom lemon peel allspice this is a
joke isn't it avocados we're serving
avocados as well no it's good for them
it's very you know obviously it's
essential fatty acid and would you like
it turned into guacamole or would you
like we do make guacamole you make
guacamole film as well and avocado
prawns avocado crab or
spinach chicory frequency iceberg
fennel spinach broccoli
we've got michelin-starred monkeys
i'm stuck here you are yes not looking
after yourself
man the gorilla's getting baby gym
lettuce absolutely you're smalling them
are you um baby gem lettuce now what is
the [ __ ] shortage for the restaurants
i know bobby's eating them
i'm going to cook hannah a deliciously
healthy dish using the same ingredients
she feeds bobby the gourmet griller with
no dairy or gluten
just to show you that all the stuff
you're working with down there yeah it
can be equally as exciting for you
first up coleslaw don't lose any
nutrients through cooking
raw is more
celeriac carrots and cabbage are all
packed with vitamins and fiber and give
the dish a delicious crunch
i love the smoky bitterness of chicory
and it's very low in cholesterol
i'm gonna make a quick vinaigrette
so
two thirds olive oil
one third sesame seed oil yeah
a little bit of mustard
okay
poppy seeds just a tablespoon makes a
great contribution to your daily calcium
needs
[Music]
lemon juice and parsley help the
digestion of proteins and fats
they also taste great
and then uh
vinegar
within three or four minutes the
seasoning's gonna start breaking down
the coleslaw
and now for my wild card
hannah's fed up with her unbalanced
boring gluten-free diet she may not have
eaten meat for three years but now she
thinks she's ready to give it another go
so i'm phoning at the deep end with a
delicious protein-rich steak
um this is the kind of beef it's reared
um in airshow yeah it's fed on grass in
the summer uh swedes and turnip in the
winter so it's a proper organic beef
when i did eat meat i would try and eat
organic
i don't like the way
animals are mass produced no i stand
strong on that one nor do i how do you
like your beef how do you like it cooked
medium yeah yeah
fine so we'll cook it more remember
okay for the dressing shallot
i believe that good quality lean meat is
a key part of a healthy diet so i'm
hoping this dish will help hannah back
on the road to recovery
turn over the steaks a delicious
tarragon dressing should make her first
fill it's taking years a little easier
to deal with so it's quite a spicy
marinade target we just cut once
slightly faster
give it a stir and add to the steaks
delicious what we're gonna do is spoon
that over so as the beef starts to cool
down
it absorbs all that amazing
flavor
finally finish the coarsely with
coriander and is ready to go
[Music]
i can't believe you can put so much
different flavors and taste just into
coleslaw
i haven't quite managed to uh
take on the beef
you put the most amazing energy into
looking after these animals so you need
protein yeah absolutely a good bit of
salmon do you think something someone
worked perfectly just not quite ready
for the uh for the red meat don't you
worry about that
i'll lose it
physical and mental limits i'm dying to
find out what fuel actually keeps them
going look at them they look absolutely
hard as nails